so I'm spider-man got in touch with me
recently and he was all like Charlie is
so cool like how you doing man
big fan listen I'm in the middle right
now a promote in my new movie the
amazing spider-man 2 out now on blu-ray
and DVD and I was just wondering how
would you feel but come on a little trip
to New York City with yours truly really
yeah bro
well we'll hook you up with a bunch of
like cool spider-man stuff to do you can
make a little video about it we could
even like hang out a little bit if you'd
like that spider-man I would be honored
and so I went to New York City joining
me on the trip were fellow spider-man
fans the artistically framed Jim Chapman
and the easily confused Jack Howard and
for our first activity we traveled to
Brooklyn to the superhero supply store
to become the heroes we were always
meant to be the short side in Super Hero
Squad it isn't just a store though in
fact it's also a front for a charity
called
8:00 to 6:00 NYC who teaches creative
writing skills to young people and so
all of the profits from the store go to
that next came trapezing which is as
close as we could get to experiencing
what it might be like to swing around
the city like spider-man trip easing is
one of those things that I don't think I
would have ever decided to do of my own
accord because it just looks so
terrifying and like it's gonna be
insanely difficult but actually turned
out to be one of the most fun things I
have ever done and I like to think I was
pretty good at it is well not not
rubbish anyway let's just say that some
other trip highlights include spending a
day with Marvel artist Riley brown
learning how to draw spider-man is my
best effort and we also went to
Forbidden Planet to check out these
spider-man comics and I bought what I'm
embarrassed to say is the first
spider-man book I have ever owned sorry
please stop judging me please stop
judging me spider-man I can tell you
doing it I can see your eyes through the
thingy you know and then they're
judgmental eyes spider-man lastly it was
time to see New York City from above
first from the top of the Empire State
Building at nighttime which was just so
incredible like the footage I got up
there just really does not do it justice
because it was amazing but then even
there got talked when afterwards we
on a freaking helicopter tour of
Manhattan all in all it was an amazing
trip I am so thankful that I got to go
on it but there was just one thing that
led me down and that was that I never
got a chance to meet spider-man
so why was that butter by the way oh
dude
genuinely I felt so bad about that I'm
sorry but I had crime too you know how
it is right I mean you couldn't have
even spared just like five minutes or
something just to say hello I mean it
was pretty letdown okay look do you
really want to know why we couldn't hang
out yeah yeah I do okay man
it goes ready get a zipper now well
spider-man obviously isn't real and
warning this is gonna get super cheesy
super quickly while I was on this trip
he did genuinely start feeling real to
me New York City love spider-man
like he pops up everywhere you go you
kind of cut escape him to be honest and
like being such a big fan of a fictional
character like that that you've loved
for so long that so many other people
loved as well that stuff can have very
real effects on your life
imagining spider-man swinging through
those tall buildings genuinely it did
make me feel more connected to the city
like meeting new people who had the same
love for the character that I do make me
love the character even more and having
something like that in common with
someone else can strengthen old
friendships and it could even build new
ones as well and while those are all
lessons that I feel like I had learned
before I came on this trip really
doesn't make any of them less awesome
when you get to experience them
firsthand so and did I really need to
buy a spider-man costume to tell you all
of that stuff well yes definitely
don't you dare question me on that okay
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like who
I swear I'm just like taking twice as
many takes of these spider-man things
just cuz I'm just like having so much
fun just like being a spy I'm not even a
good spider-man I know it I just like
look like a dope and I'm not even doing
an American accent just like what the
hell is going on
give a care in the world fill a lot
McArdle or this Spidy rubbish stuff but
I'm just like having fun having a great
day so just think I might just go out
like this